no we're swapping Egyptian and American
snacks the equivalents of the American
snacks to the Egyptians oh okay we're
gonna see which one tastes better
I'm kind of excited to try something new
I feel like whatever snacks we got for
American I'm probably asked probably
like I have barbecue lays it's barbecue
this is for the no it's a product
derivative from gypsum has lime in it
and spices cumin oh my god this human
the smell it's intense its UI interface
I like news on estates by there's a
little more flavor oh you gotta savor
that you gotta savor it that's the
American classic however you want to try
one I think they use honey in their
barbecue sauce that's what makes us wait
right it's really light I mean it's not
really like 60% less bad I'm sticking
with fusion right here champagne
how do you translate sure my din candle
holders
what is that the translation for her
this is childhood I think I had these
like when I was going to middle schools
like third grade I haven't had these in
forever
[Music]
mm-hmm
first fast nobody you're not supposed to
eat an egg guys it sounds like that sort
of never mind let me see if this still
this is yeah yeah what's the name of us
again that's John my date as Sheridan
which is translated
chandelier chandelier Mina fancy dabba
do this my friend is smoothie of
strawberries and yogurt but dude does
that buys ever do this is ever delivered
ooh
this is a childhood dream and this isn't
your cupboard you know that your parents
for women you know that your family as a
whole was solid
we got a tricky when there's like oh
that want milk it's like no but don't
want a friend yeah when you eat yogurt
what do you feel sexy now this is good
though this is definitely like a yogurt
tea smoothie that's like milk it is milk
actually it's good I think it's good I
think it's safe to say we can we can
call this a even from fancy packaging to
mmm this is fantastic
did you finish it I did you really did
finish it I was very happy however
that's amazing
bamboo I was waiting for this one
no those I haven't had since I was maybe
five
why are you giving him all the good I
yes I've seen those in the gas station
moonpies bimbo bin low respectively oh
yeah
Cheers can't wait Ethan I came to the
law that's pretty good let's talk about
the word bimbo let's talk about your
childhood America baby there's nothing
more American outside of GM this is a
milk chocolate for me growing up I liked
it because it wasn't as sweet Oh
okay so what I like about this already
is that these have like a little pocket
in there so if you just want to like
play with it in your mouth like it's so
small it melts in your mouth not in your
hand
those aren't the Hershey's this
Hershey's is good do you bite it a day
just like it was butter tastes like
butter okay Newton's also known as Fig
Newtons I like them so this is my moon
my moon so my moon is made with dates
could be some dates Scotty oh I see
where we have the dates smells good
tastes good I know
oh yeah look if you like I still do what
a date tastes like this guy's I've had
cookie are you a singer yes oh you
should thank you let me hit my nose
Frodo stick inside them something called
Haleiwa it comes from sesame seed it's
almost like our peanut butter
you know the tahini sauce no it's a No
hello hello a little higher hi Leigh
Leigh where where did you get in there
did you get in there you smell test good
this is all wrong yes before it's pretty
freakin good it's sweet it's like that
it took me a minute on this nano what's
going on
don't like it tastes like something I
just don't know
it's like got peanut butter but it
doesn't have like the full like nutty
taste of peanut butter I'm gonna go with
the homie here
[Music]
Oh
[Music]